are you do you do a lot of yoga no
no are you on a second to the LA thing
well maybe I don't know are you are you
very early do you do you eat a lot of
kale I do and that makes you calm
it makes you a lot of things
I'm kind of scared and kind of turned on
clearly you don't read your fan mail
I can't find me I sent you
I sent you a card and when I told your
assistant that I loved your book she was
like you read his book I thought his
assistant doesn't even read his fan mail
yeah no I I swear I didn't I didn't get
a card I wrote you a card I never got a
response and I was very heartbroken well
I I I I I'm I apologize right now
because I'm looking for I just wanted an
apology
thank you oh no absolutely thank you
take your dress off
[Applause]
[Music]
so do not wearing a bra
really well that's good we're having a
good time already no we are I'm having
an excellent time although I'm wearing a
bra because but I'm older than you yeah
that's what happens with age I I love
I've had two children I have had two
children oh they start to you need a
little more help I think mine were doing
that before the kids came along really
why are you rubbing my chair like this
is that is is that a bone villain thing
you'd be a good bone villain actually I
think this is you know you so I'm
subliminally maybe doing what I whoa
this might be a
oh no he drives me in a bra good job let
me Flex let me Flex you know I actually
do have a crush on is uh Beth the
executive that
honestly not bad I think you do a great
job I think it's tough out here you know
no I I know I feel around a little bit
and stuff but I would so do you
foreign
sexy girl
thank you sir I'm hanging in there no I
mean it's uh it's really well what are
you doing what are you doing
I do
just like that you just use that machine
fantastic may I say that look at you wow
that green dress that draws the eye hey
I'll be honest the green dress on its
own would not draw my eye but with you
in it suddenly there I am with my eyes
drawn so you like it there I do New York
is such a great City to be yes it is
yeah did you ever do any modeling by any
chance
um yeah yeah did you do the runway
modeling yeah oh right yes uh I I
imagine you probably did yeah yeah
normally I can speak uh but
not today having a bit of a hard time
this evening don't know what it is it's
kind of hot in the studio I'm feeling a
little
is it hot in here well you're wearing
them so um
yeah
um uh uh uh
I'm good I'm good yeah I love your blue
eyes I love everything about you
laughs
and and he's gay yeah
yeah not anymore yeah
I I'm really I'm good you know to eat
and yeah
of course
[Applause]
thank you I'm here to help all right
I like that I like you
you look great you look so yeah healthy
thank you thanks so much I feel healthy
you look very healthy indeed have you
been have you been working out at all I
have a lot yeah well because in the show
you take your clothes off a lot
constantly I I wonder do you have any
DVD copies
yes I do actually yeah I quite like to
see I'm having trouble keeping my eyes
in one place Jennifer
why is that well they keep falling
after all this time I haven't seen you
for all this time and I'm not looking at
you at all
I've seen you for ages and I'm like hey
what's up oh yeah that's good I think
you're hearing your TVs that'll really
make it okay
what is that that looks like a pilot on
your desk what is that yeah well in a
way it is it's a large snake cup because
I'm insecure about my penis have you
ever come across that in the mountain
before have I ever come across your
penis well have you Chelsea have you no
but you're one of the comedians that I
would have had sex with I know you're a
married man now so I would never do that
now of course neither would you I hope
and I but I I thought you were very sexy
the first time I came on I did and then
I found out you were sober and I was
like oh forget it oh come on
did you just meow me there you meowed me
you went yeah your legs are here they
are
pretend to bring me wow I mean they
don't just get you around they you're
traveling in style their getaway sticks
yeah there's you got a that's a Europe
well done uh you got your is that the
shorts you've got on there yeah I'm
wearing shorts I noticed yep yeah thank
you oh love jazz love blues and I heard
you play a mouth organ that I want you
to know
a little bit later I also play the
harmonica
[Applause]
you really are a fan of jazz yeah no I
am I did this uh I did this movie in New
Orleans last summer and I got really
into the blues and every now we went out
to a different jazz blues bar and the
harmonica just really kind of just got
into my blood yeah it's good do you play
yourself and I no I just got one though
and I want to learn so maybe you can be
my teacher no no I can't maybe I could
is that the sore leg yes the doctor told
me to elevate it so here we go
no
this is a Late Late Show right
it is now yeah where are you from you
asked me I did ask you that yes see
exactly I know exactly uh region it's
quiet
I'm gonna answer the question now all
right
do you cream
foreign
yeah right there when you did that to my
hand
we have to take a break do I get to come
back well you can stay there no I stay
here and I don't go anywhere well you
could leave put it on abroad come back
or or
not or you can stay here I'd like to
stay I'd like to stay it's going to be a
long commercial break you'll have me oh
I I will thank you thank you will you
pound me though
oh
no
well
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you just smell your finger
may I
know you how long have you been married
now already on that yeah just trying to
keep up on it see how it's going uh
let's see it's been November December
January almost four months okay that's
the tricky period
yeah it's it's starting to get Rocky you
know you have a nice Valentine's Day
first Valentine's Day married
um yeah I I kind of dropped the ball
Craig
thank you
I don't think anyone would mind
just pick it up keep going
yeah you know it's a nice little town
where everybody knows your name and you
get a very nice like humble grounded
upbringing and you you know you learn
your yes ma'ams your no sirs your
pleases and thank yous and guns as well
a lot of guns as you you saw how easily
is that is that for real that was real
you really can fire a gun yeah that was
a 45 I find that very very attractive in
a woman
I think there's something very
attractive about knowing how is it yeah
that's good too that's also good that
little thing what the hell is that human
people do that oh look my hands really
appears coming to get you
well hello well hello you
oh
yeah and that
that is that is the closest you'll get
to sex on this show okay you look great
I mean wow thanks I wore this just for
you guys like to match your mug it's a
snake brace hat what is that a hand
bracelet it's a really classy handcuff
should we get a safety word going
last time I was here I had a red dress
on oh I remember
[Music]
how you feel and then is that a oh it's
a microphone all right yeah I always
walk with a microphone that's good in
case you need to report to someone
you put a microphone on like that
backstage do our certain men put it on
you or do you do
um no he was in there he unzipped my
back of my dress it gets very intimate
yeah
I got the wrong job here